violin virtuoso Gidon Kremer performing
together with some of the musicians from
the Kramer auto baltika ensemble for an
evening of exclusively Latvian music
from this wunderbar it was I think it's
wonderful that something is being done
for the music I'll lift the citrus for
my hymen is great that something is
being done for my own country Latvia
cling in this latter years of musical
place Leticia gazenga and laughs Ian
songs latest slightly in music since I
can find a wider audience through events
like these the german finance ministry
was originally built as the Luftwaffe
headquarters back in the 1930s its halls
now echo with the sound of the Baltic
wire
many of latvia's for most musicians have
come to take part in the performance it
lasts for four hours the zoo linked or
oppa series or loosely translated the
sounds of Europe is open to the public
350 people are attending this evening
euro Max's own mica Kruger hosted the
festivities the music was accompanied by
discussions one participant was Finance
Minister Wolfgang Shore blah he once
played the violin himself said was it's
ian is Novas concerned us making music
is a special integrity and experiencing
people making music up close and
personal e is also special yeah nothing
can compare to it then overpays vicetone
deceives oh this event is aimed at
teaching people who are interested in
Europe's richness once Danny do the
things about it that are specific and
simple hiding and by plane it is the far
side up for middle that's what this
building also provides a wealth of
options and has excellent acoustics ODI
acoustic
one of the most successful lat few
musicians of the younger generation is
Lima jaan Sona she's considered a master
of her traditional Latvian instrument
it's quickly and yes exactly this kind
of instrument comes exactly from Latvia
of course there are relative instruments
for example in Finland there is can tell
and also another baltic states there's
relative instruments but instrument with
this kind of sound playing techniques
and pronunciation walkley is just an
only from latvia
the name mellow em is a combination of
the words melody and mania this cello
trio are at times willing to sacrifice
the first in favor of the second
bass guitar and walk off so that's the
main idea because the cello is it can
play bass telecom play play the middle
side the retina make instrument and
melodic instrument so that's the main
concept of the three cellos that we can
do full spectrum of the music largely an
artist agata ab khana is in the midst of
what's called live painting one work is
to be finished each evening it's part of
the concept of the series Europe is
growing together and artists are doing
their part to make it happen is
happening humid so it appears I've
always person I felt like a European my
mother's because my native language is
actually German looks mmm but I grew up
in Latvia while my grandfather was
Swedish and Latvia is part of Europe ooh
the sounds of Latvia in Germany's
Ministry of Finance and other countries
will also get to perform here in the
coming year
you